couldn't believe my name was Daniel
Radcliffe and it was on the credits list
I landed in this extraordinary part when
I was 11 but whoever had got this part
would have been receiving this these
levels of sort of crowds and you just
have to keep remembering that it's not
about you it's about you know the series
and how iconic the character is we're
putting down we're just such good
friends no we no we've got a very strong
friendship
just the whole of that film really I
just I just spent with my mouth on the
floor I was just in awe of everything
and it was all so exciting it went by in
a Flash everybody will
it's gonna be weird that's gonna be
scary I saw the billboard it's scary I
would be that big it's just scary it's
hard to really kind of imagine what life
is going to be without this because it's
kind of kind of taken over my life